protesters again at the front gate of
the governor's mansion aiming their
anger at the interim governor they
didn't even vote for but have been told
is the best option to leave Puerto Rico
they disagree to corporate interests
she's referring to Pedro Pierluisi the
new governor who previously worked at a
law firm that represented a company
accused of polluting the islands
groundwater with toxic ash Pierluisi is
from the largest political party the new
progressives he's a former justice
minister who also served as Puerto
Rico's representative to Washington he
was sworn in late Friday even though he
was not confirmed for the Senate as
required by law the Senate will vote on
Monday and he could be forced to step
down if he doesn't get the confirmation
votes he needs the people of Puerto Rico
took to the streets to demand change
they got it but for many of them it
wasn't the change they want while
Pierluisi has not been directly tied to
corruption those who want to see the
most change view him and the government
he now leads the suspicion they are all
corrupt they have all been allegedly
implying in the same corruption schemes
the governor was taken out put so if
they think the people of Puerto Rico are
going to conform or going to simply
decide let's settle for the less than
two evils we're not we're tired of this
and we know that the next two years are
gonna be fundamental in the
restructuring of Puerto Rico so we
really need someone competent and honest
to represent us and they say they won't
stop until they have it April's Ando al
Jazeera San Juan Puerto Rico